hey guys don't Walker here um something
I've noticed is that whenever I do sort
of these lists of like my top 10
favorites are just whatever movies I
like everyone else dislikes and vice
versa people really seem to like that
stuff and they seem to like it more when
it's not scripted so I decided I'm gonna
do a few more of these just sort of
general chat about um what I personally
like and don't like in terms of movies
and shows inspirations all that good
stuff and for the most part it's gonna
be off the cuff I mean there's gonna be
a little bit editing but so it's sort of
like a semi blog and if you like it keep
watching them I'm probably gonna be
doing a few more of them so with that
said I am going to do because a lot of
people keep asking I'm gonna do my top
favorite comedic influences these are
the people and creations that really
influenced my sense of humor now pretty
much and once again I'm putting it all
together and it was gonna be a top 10
but Damon I can't keep it a top 10 so I
had to go top 15 it's my list so I can
do whatever I want
so these are the top 15 people
I shouldn't say top 15 comedic
influences that have the biggest impact
on me growing up
Robin Williams now I don't even think I
got to talk about why this guy is so
good
it's his improv technique it is
fantastic you seem a stand-up you're
never gonna get the same show twice I
love his energy I love how fast he is I
love how he loves interacting with
people I love there's a sense that he's
not afraid of anything when he goes up
there to perform but what I also love I
do have sort of this soft v force or the
vaudeville delivery if it's done well I
mean a lot of times it's done really bad
but the comedians are Sir keeping it
alive and doing that delivery well I
really respect as the diff sort of going
back to the roots where a lot of these
Performing comedians came from so I as
you know I'm not always a famous movie
choices um but I think he can act and he
can act very well well what else can
even say about he's an improv genius I
mean he just goes on an interview and he
won't shut up with the jokes his life is
just comedy comedy throwing comedy at
you but at the same time he seems very
very intelligent to like when you've
entered him to calm down and you talk to
him for real he seems like a really
smart guy and he seems really
intelligent so I enjoy his jokes they're
very smart very quick love his energy
what else can you say about miss Robin
Williams number 14
Dave Chappelle now even though this guy
sir came in later in my whatever comedic
development whatever you want to call it
um you really didn't have an influence
on me because I think it's sort of a
perfect mix between really shocking
humor and cartoony humor and I really
like that mix I like sort of the mix of
the really adult and really childish and
he brings those two together so well um
here stand up to do it but like
everybody I fell in love with the
Chappelle's Show and there's just
something about him I think even he said
like one of his biggest influences is
Bugs Bunny and you can see that he
really when you see the way he says a
line or again he sir has that wink to
the camera and that smile shock humor
today of course has to be very adult and
very risque but I like it when people
combine it with something from are you
something very cartoony and he does that
so much you know the other thing with
the Chappelle show the timing is great
the editing phenomenal I don't know if
you ever really concentrating the
editing in that show but it's some of
the best comedic editing you'll ever see
they know just when to cut just when to
go to the next shot just went to hold on
a shot long enough I mean they I don't
know if you had any saying that you
probably did but it that's part of what
made that show just so good is the
editing was just so crisp and so fast
and knew exactly when the stop know
exactly how long to go so and I also
liked the idea of combining the stand up
with comedic sketches I thought was a
very clever way of doing things I think
a lot of comedians wish they could do
that actually so I get very
straightforward people love them Dave
Chappelle
number thirteen enemy the X okay yeah
you've heard me go on on and on about
this show I mean it's it's gradually
pointless to talk about it but let's
talk about a little bit premise is great
the timing wonderful I love the fact
that they're really trying to recreate
the Looney Tunes but sort of mix it with
the variety show and that's something
that I think is a big deal
variety shows used to be really really
big at Carol Burnett who was wonderful
actually would be on this list if maybe
she came in my life a little younger but
um you know that's a wonderful show a
laugh-in and a lot of these are shows
the only one we really have still and
even then it's sort of loose is SNL
which still has sketches and songs you
know but it's well there's two song
performances and it's pretty much just
these sketches they all have a certain
amount of time there's not much variety
to it Animaniacs seem to really bring
back the variety show for kids at least
and it was really nice a lot of things
didn't have to be an exact amount long
and of course is sort of segue into
whatever and what's great about
Animaniacs is also what's great about
something like Family Guy is that they
really take advantage of the fact that
it's animation it's not like hey this is
just a live-action sketch show but with
cartoons I mean they take advantage of
the fact that you can do anything with
animation and the even the setups I mean
two little mice don't want to take over
the world I mean that's you can't do
that in live-action or at least it
wouldn't be as funny so you know or the
old cartoon character that knows all the
tricks you know what slappy and all that
stuff I mean these are just great these
characters are great they practically
seem alive and the timing they have is
wonderful the jokes are great great
variety of jokes both very childish just
straight to the kids and then very adult
straight to the adults look at the top
11 da da mini a moment you know I'm
talking about
and yet huge influence on me growing up
definitely never missed an episode
growing up I mean just really really
took a lot from their humor so like I
said as if I haven't said it
number 12
Bill Murray I can't explain what it is
there's just something about the way he
performs the way he talks the way he
acts he is so comfortable with what he
is and he also enjoys it so much it just
happens to be a jerk you know and most
jerks when you see them in and I love
these jerks you know are uncomfortable
they're very unsatisfying they're you
know it shows all the weaknesses Bill
Murray is just so cool with how smug he
is and and just how funny he is and now
I'm talking about sort of the care of
the people I don't know the actual
person is like that here he is
I don't know but yeah the people he
plays in these movies are just so much
fun and I think there's something where
even though he's a jerk he's so relaxed
and he's so comfortable with it with it
that you become comfortable with it as
well so I haven't seen him do much
stand-up or anything and even on SNL
you're always server where you're
watching Bill Murray which is both an
advantage and a disadvantage um if you
like Bill Murray you'll really really
like watching his stuff about that
something like Jeff Goldblum where you
see once and you're done
oh you're just gonna see that over and
over over it's not gonna work
so I mean luckily I really enjoyed Bill
Murray I like seeing him in these movies
you know ghostbusters loss of
translation you know these are great
movies um and yeah I like I said just a
comfortableness with how smug he is and
I think when you're really confident in
who you are and the jokes you're saying
it brings other people and I think he's
very very good at that so I guess it's
sort of a no-brainer a lot of people
enjoy em I enjoy optic
number one Rowan Atkinson now here's the
thing about Rowan Atkinson I like him
more for some of the stuff that's not as
popular I like him more for Blackadder
some of you had seen that you know the
Hugh Laurie you know dr. house he came
from there I actually cannot watch house
because of the show blackhat or I keep I
keep thinking - Laurie's gonna you know
dress up in drag it's something like
that cuz that's what I did did in one
episode so but anyway Roy Atkinson I
liked him more as the jerk the mr. bean
stuff he's sort of a jerk too but it's
sort of a naive innocent jerk it's a
little child basically and that's very
funny - I like his mr. bean stuff but
the stuff where I think he shines the
best is when he's this you know just
miserable intelligent but just miserable
human being never gets what he wants and
makes everybody suffer because of it and
just so pompous but also again very
intelligent and you he can make you
sympathize with the fact that he
deserves more but for some reason he's
not getting it and it's probably
attitude it's probably because of his
attitude that things don't fall in his
lap and he's always working for the
idiot and that's just such a great
character on top of that mr. bean the
physical performance and that's why I
like about Rowan Atkinson you have you
know if you want character you go to
Black Adder
you know you go that's the great
character development if you want the
physical comedy you go to mr. bean and I
think that's great that you have those
two extremes
you know back-to-back and they really
work out well so I I really enjoy Rowan
Atkinson's work even than something like
rat race which is almost over a repeat
of mr. bean I there's such this joy in
this innocence I love the fact he can go
extreme miserable with mr. bean and
extreme positive and you know naive and
Wyatt wide-eyed and stuff and still make
it funny it's very hard to make positive
characters funny even though you can
start arguing
negativities don't cuz he is like a
little kid but when he's but what people
usually like about mr. penis wait mr.
bean is why he's very positive like when
he was playing with the nativity scene
in the Christmas episode with the
dinosaur and stuff why is that doing
this be mean he's having fun you know he
doesn't know any better and I think
people really relate to how excited he
is and how he sees them like action
figures so I really like Rowan Atkinson
because he can get both the really
negative and the really positive and
make them both very very funny so that's
a real good talent there number 10 daily
shelling The Colbert Report I should
just call it Comedy Central News but
both these guys they in a sense they
sort of do the same thing so I pulled
both in the same category and both have
had a really large influence
particularly on the nostalgia critic I
think with Jon Stewart I'm really
impressed with how Jon Stewart has sort
of become like this voice of reason even
though he does this comedy show and it's
a it's perfect because with comedy
you can if you start making really
strong points people say yeah he's
making a really troubling if you make a
point that doesn't work you just say oh
well I'm a dummy comedy I'm supposed to
be a dumb comedian so it's actually sort
of foolproof if you do it right at Jon
Stewart has figured that out so which is
really great now some people complain
that you know he makes too many strong
you know movements for you know his site
which he has very left people come on I
mean for the people it's like no no he's
done that though he's very left he will
make jokes at the left which is great I
saw that air view with Obama at the in
the last year and that that that was a
great interview but yeah he did pretty
left you know but it doesn't matter they
will still make fun of both sides which
I do really respect um but I think
there's something again he's one of the
few people that can look at the camera
and laugh and sort of you know do the
shrug thing and it works for some reason
there's something about he obviously
shows how intelligent he is and yeah
obviously shows he even though I think
he is very loved he wants to give both
sides sort of a chance you know he does
like that he acknowledges that there's
problem with both sides
so like I say he gets a lot of
credibility and even when a joke fails
he has fun with it and he can have other
people joke with it you know since he
never takes it too seriously he's always
ready to fall back into a stupid joke
which I really like
Colbert Report I like him for similar
reasons but the main one is that he's
created this character and it's
incredible how much he sticks to his
character I both written and improvised
it's phenomenal
I mean I've never seen anyone stick to a
character so consistently for so long
and so well um and the way he uses the
backwards logic to always bring it back
to he's always right is so well done and
it's you can tell it's not just the
writers though of course they have a
very very that they do a lot of it when
he's talking with somebody you know in
an interview and stuff I mean just the
how quick he is to have these responses
and always work it back to he's correct
is so brilliant and I can't think of any
other community and I've seen there's
been that good added maybe even our
comedian decide to take that I like if
Robin Williams may decide to do that
possibly he could do it but Colbert is
just born to do this
and he does it so wonderfully and it's
it's very very well done he does it very
very well so both these shows have like
some of the best writers I can't believe
how consistently good these writers are
but they both have really good main
talents if I had to choose which one's
more talented probably Colbert because
like I said he is sticking to this
character no matter what it's Stewart as
Stewart is great but I get he does the
you know sort of the fight for the
people I you know the voice of reason
and stuff like that which is wonderful
fantastic but I just take away a little
bit from the comedy so but again you get
some very good points out of it so so
they're both equally wonderful but I
think oh there's maybe a little bit more
talent but both are fantastic and both
do their job incredibly well if you're
watching this now for Greg he could
I take a lot from both of them so yeah
really good stuff we're not the sucker
brothers and Jim Abraham's now everybody
always says the sucker brother's the
sucker brother movies they forget Jim
Abrams was a big part of that too if you
want proof of that when they split one
of the Zucker brothers split and Jim
Abraham's when it did his stuff to um
you know none of them quite hit that
level of you know hilarity a navy rat
race but you know them hit the hilarity
of like you know airplane or hotshots or
anything the one that came close to
keeping that style though was should
Abraham's with mafia which is sort of
underrated it's not that bad of film it
doesn't totally work but it's not that
bad it's got some really memorable jokes
in there and that's the closest to sort
of the formula they created with you
know the hotshot movies and make a gun
um so I put those three together and
something about again it's sort of that
cartoony style mixed with naughty humor
I'm a big fan of visual jokes like even
the ones that I know we're stupid for
example in mafia there's a scene where
that this guy is gangster he's trying to
shoot this kid he's in the forest hey
shoots the gun it hits the tree the tree
girls okay and falls over dead laughs my
ass off
I don't know why maybe because there's a
silly part of me that wants to see that
you know I think maybe because as
children we were raised on cartoons we
have a more active imagination with
visual jokes so when we do see visual
joke in the back of our head were think
would it be funny of this happened um
they sort of do that they they go with
the jokes that you sort of want to see
happen when you're watching a movie and
you know a serious movie and sometimes
you get the giggles there's some visuals
you want to see and I think they tap
into that and I think they tapped into
it really really well so and I like the
fact that the parodies now and this
isn't going you know my work when we do
the sad tires we sort of directly point
at what we're making fun though for
example like in scary movie three
Charlie Sheen says you know when they're
sanitizing signs he says what they can
master space travel but they can't get
through a door
you know that's directly attacking signs
in something like in Hacha
it's a little bit more subtle like this
can exist on its own you don't have to
have seen Top Gun or Rambo or anything
like that you know that they the jokes
they make it's satirizing but it's also
self-contained and I do have a respect
for that I think that's usually the much
better way to go in the movies usually
lasts a lot better because people forget
the details with some of these other
films but even as a kid I met I didn't
see Top Gun you know as a kid but I
could see hotshots and laugh and still
find it funny so a big respect for those
guys if you haven't seen the Kentucky
Fried movie that's like probably their
first film it's just a bunch of sketches
but the very funny stuff little
perverted but very very funny stuff and
these three were just so great I'd love
to see him get back together again and
do some sort of movie project I think
you do like Laura the Rings or something
like how come nobody's you know the
satire movies are so dead right now I
mean they can really bring it back and
they can really be flanked us there's
some good movie franchises that can be
satirized you know the the Star Wars
prequels the Harry Potter's the Lord of
the Rings I need franchises are huge
right now why aren't they making good
satires you know instead of just making
the satire before they see the film you
know just spend some time at make it
funny they can still work everyone's
saying it's dead know you can make it
work you know just have fun with it
so yeah that's all I gotta say about
that
no right
South Park now these guys are a huge
influence because they're still going
they're still going and they're doing it
with very little really think about the
animation is still awful it's awful
animation but it still has good timing
what they're saying is funny and they're
not taking any prisoners that they it
seems like they really don't care what
anybody thinks they're just gonna say
their opinion even if it's really
unpopular a lot of times of this popular
but there's a good during the time where
it is not popular and they just go that
route and it's great because it it
doesn't seem like they have to throw
much money into it so whatever if an
episode doesn't do well it loses money
or something uh they still got a ton you
know it's such a big hit and I really
admire that direct honesty that direct
here's our opinion here's what we see do
you see this - because this is what
we're seeing if not we're gonna have fun
with it anyway um and they do it so well
I really like the fact these the
character I really love the most in a
show I'm sure everybody loves the most
is Cartman because he is such a horrible
despicable creation and the fact that
he's a kid just makes it even more funny
because it just makes him even more sort
of you don't want to pay attention to
him like you know there's no need to pay
attention to a me solve is just this
emotional little complainer but the fact
that when he does get power when he does
become powerful that's I love stuff like
that I love it when the person who is
not important doesn't say anything of
importance is just a total jerk gets all
this power and there's a lot of times
where that's happened so really love
that character and I love the fact the
you know and some that does become dated
but what's interesting about South Park
is that even when they sanitize
something it becomes dated they're sad
tires are so funny that people actually
remember the event because of the satire
and that's real talent that's really
really good and I see myself
I don't usually think of South Park that
much I get don't usually quote a
reference in my head or anything like
that but I do find myself realizing yeah
it's
there it's it's really embedded in there
and I don't think about that much if I
usually I'm like oh so far what I don't
want watch that lowbrow humor but
whenever I watch it hilarious always
something funny in there so it's very
funny how that works out how there's
this you know incredibly immature comedy
that's going on but there's also this
great social satire that they're just
directly aiming at and a good end of the
time I do agree with them and even if I
don't it's still good food for thought
it's still fun to listen to so really
like these guys I like them because they
keep going they're still fresh they're
still funny and they do it with very
very little which you know for us
there's a big beautiful hones you know I
mean what we don't throw a you know a
shitload of money into our productions
you know we keep it very simple we're
hoping that's the content that makes it
you know still last so I but like I said
I really admire the fact that they're
still around and they're still doing
very very well and it's still very very
French and you still can't predict what
they're going to do or what they're
going to say and that's really great
yeah we can only hope to be that awesome
number seven
Mel Brooks again sort of the semi
vaudeville thing going on I really enjoy
how sometimes it becomes a little too
vaudeville I'm not gonna lie you know
some of these jokes are like really did
that joke but again sort of part of the
fun you know you will say yeah well
we'll do this you know I don't care if
it's lame I'm gonna do it because I like
it and I think you do sense that passion
in a lot of his movies I think the only
point where I started to kind of lose it
I liked Robin Hood men in tights enough
but then it was the Dracula and came
around I'm like but before that I'm not
even after that the Broadway producers I
hear was very very good it didn't like
the movie too much I'm not doing an old
versus new that I mean in terms of the
new movie in the old movie because the
new movie obviously won't win that the
old movie is fantastic and she wilder
and zero myself how can you beat those
guys I don't care if you get Nathan Lane
Matthew Broderick ok movies dead um so
anyway Mel Brooks I really really
enjoyed because the these are just such
classic set ups and they're sort of
classic jokes
what really makes at the play that
Blazing Saddles ok I watched that
recently that is more shocking now than
it was back then I'm saying cuz I
remember watching this and they're
watching us as a kid now like a
five-year-old or anything but you know I
saw this movie was young I knew what
look whatever word was um and whether I
got through it fine and I know that
people whatever in the 70 of Richard
Pryor's dies I'm Richard Pryor don't
write that movie um you know was doing a
lot of the wench of a boozy you know was
saying the N word a lot and stuff like
that so it's nothing super shocking it's
even said now but the fact that a movie
that big in that public you know it did
that well it's such a well-known con me
if you watch it again this would not fly
today it I mean they would not air this
movie you know the amount of times that
they say that word and the way they use
it and a lot of the jokes they would not
run
this movie and it's really fascinating
because of that um on top of that again
just the very generous or a cartoony
humor vaudeville humor the other movie
that really stands out to me well the
two producers really stands out to me
brilliant kind of simple love it just
the fantastic setup for a movie you got
two great actors pulling it off and you
just love watching them and then the
other one of course is Spaceballs love
Spaceballs again mostly because of the
villains the villains are so good and
that's what is what's interesting that
Mel Brooks does he creates the satire
you know they were basically sad tears
but he creates these characters as well
it's like he does want to create a story
that goes through and sucker brothers
sort of do that too but the characters
are mostly there for the jokes Mel
Brooks will actually create these
characters like you want to remember
these characters and you like these
characters you know Charlie Sheen in
hotshot you know do great but I mean
it's just he's there to be a satire of
Tom Cruise you know what's in the the
girlfriend those movies was pretty she
star had her own character but anyway um
but yeah they're usually just cetera you
know Leslie Nielsen is a satire of the
cops from these movies you know a Bill
Pullman is sort of his own character you
know dark helmet is kind of his own
character Colonel Sanders and whether
the president of plants pays well
they're their own characters they exist
on their own and that's what I really
like about Mel Brooks I like the fact
that he creates these characters in this
satirical world and that it makes them
seem more three-dimensional that way so
it's a very interesting thing to do to
sort of create your own characters that
even if you took him out of Spaceballs
if you took him out of the parody they
could have a movie somewhere else they
can have their own story so I really
enjoy Mel Brooks because of that
Notah six goofy cartoons and Tom and
Jerry cartoons and not sort of a weird
thing to put on the list I should say
the team that brought us the goofy
cartoons in the time of Jerry cartoons
but they're both very similar and I like
them for the same reasons that's why I
put together the goofy goofy cartoons it
has to be a sports cartoon it can't be
one where and it can't be one where he's
all of those are okay the ones where
there's a lot of Goofy's like the tennis
one or the basketball one who could get
the hockey one so funny out of football
right here I'll get to in a second it's
great because you see goofy like you
don't usually see and like goofy can
look Amin in those cartoons I mean you
can get this really angry face and the
fact that they're all the same they're
all these Goofy's uh it just makes the
world they create much more desperate
and sort of power-hungry and they all
want to win you know it's that great
competition that they're all gonna go
out of their way and fight each other
and go through the slapstick just to get
the ball you know for something so
pathetically think about to just win
this case but it's how far they'll go
and that's very much like sports
you know just the desperation they'll go
you know to to achieve this goal to
achieve this goal to win a sport you
know when you really think about it it
shouldn't be anything that grand but we
do invest so much in it and I love
watching the Disney cartoons because of
that but like I say it has to be the
ones with the teams uh and actually the
interesting thing the football episode
of with goofy we actually watch every
Super Bowl we watch it at halftime
because we love that cartoon so much it
just makes us laugh so much
um so never fails always gets a laugh
out of us just great timing great
slapstick the best ones got to be the
hockey one that one just the ending of
that is so insane I actually satirize if
you ever saw a Scarface in five seconds
I satirise it and use some of those
clips but yes those are really great the
Tom and Jerry episodes um
again great timing great violence the
you know the pure
lust for violence in these cartoons are
just so wonderful and it's one of the
things we sort of think you know
whatever miles you get someone it's
funny no it has to be done a certain way
there is a great like scientific way of
looking at slapstick you know if we're
having it done right um you know and I
think you can have to sort of see this
with some of the water bars the like wit
like with Tiny Toons no matter why watch
it as a kid the early episodes when
someone got hit you know the the face
would get really weird and out there and
go oh no that's not funny what's funny
is that when the object looks more solid
when it hits someone and it really looks
like it hits them and they fly back you
know it has to really look solid the
person the person can't look rubbery
you know and plasticky because then it
doesn't look like the pain is as much as
all those things but it's the amount of
pain is what makes it funny you know it
is all based on misery and Tomic Jerry
just had that so well I think my
favorite bit is whenever Tom look to
things whenever Tom screams fantastic
that's always a bill Hannah doing that
scream if you didn't know about Bill
Hannah
it could be barbaric I'm pretty sure it
was Hannah and the other thing I love is
that whenever well Thomas he's great
eyebrows if you ever know us there so
it'll ask for a lot of expression you
know so when he wants really being is
that you want to see him get hit but you
also sympathize with the fact that he
whatever he wants to either you know get
a meal or he wants to stop Jerry from
whatever he's doing but never enough to
see him not kid injured my favorite
thing that Tom does is whenever he
thinks he won the day he just does this
little smile he just sticks his chin out
like this and it's great and it's you
know it's just saying hit me he said no
come on hit me I'm so confident I can be
able to hit me you know apply any damage
and then whatever and and no comes it
hits him or something like that but it's
that expression right before he gets hit
and that's what they did best they did
the best expressions just before the
violence happened yeah when someone goes
oh you know or looks more angry
huh BAM you know it's they got that down
so perfect it had such good timing you
know with the violence so and again
those screams are hilarious but I'm just
repeating myself so both those cartoons
you know they get some misses but you
know both those cartoons did their
slapstick and their timing so well that
for me they're just irresistible I love
number five Louis black now this is the
guy at first I still sort of do and
nostalgia crack I'm not gonna lie you
know I do take a lot from him this was
the first really angry comedian I saw
that I sort of said I I want to be like
this good this guy has something that's
really really funny and again it is sort
of cartoony just how angry his
expressions and I like the way he can go
through like five expressions in two
seconds
you know it's it's great and the way
there's a sense that you can always sort
of see the vein in his hand just he's
always shaking even when he's not like
if you ever known his ways just talking
serious or something like that like it
still kind of shake I mean you get the
fact this really isn't an uptight guy
but he has so much fun with it and the
anger you can always feel like he's
trying to hold back the anger and it
always comes out of little spurts and he
wants to let out more but he's trying to
be polite
do you know for the audience or whatever
and again I think a lot of us can you
know relate to there's a lot of times
where we want to say something we want
to say no you were wrong but you're
trying to be nice you're grinning
through your teeth and stuff like that
and at some point you know he comes out
and explodes and that's always the big
payoff but again it's a great it's a
great sort of character he's created
even if it is or isn't him this is
probably a little bit of him in there
but I don't know I think a lot of it's a
character he knows it's a lot of
character um but just the anger that
he's trying to hold back but constantly
fail
and holding back I think that's where
his comedy comes from is that he's
trying to be dignified he's trying to be
humble a good person but he's so bad at
it and he has so much anger it just
can't be contained um and it just kills
me I think if you watch a lot of the
older nostalgic rakes you can see
especially I'm taking a lot from Louis
black I think even one or two it
whenever I go like this I'm taking from
Lewis my cuz he I don't do this because
that's his there I won't directly steal
but you know the point in the finger I
mean that's direct Louis black so very
very funny and interesting when you
consider you know sort of how old he is
and when he became really famous for his
stand-up I mean he was real he was like
his 40s or 50s or something like that he
still has all that anger and all that
angst and and and so much energy so I
think everybody likes Louis black hockey
and not I I wish more will be done with
him in movies I can see him as a main
character in a movie why won't they give
him a movie like write a good script you
know all the movies he's been have been
terrible you know and they're just
giving him side parts so I somebody
write a movie for Lewis Black with a
good you know screenplay a good funny
setup or scenario cuz he deserves a
movie you know he deserves to be the
star of a movies so obviously taking a
lot from him a lot of people can see
that great comedian if you ever see him
before
look him up
number four Monty Python everybody knows
Monty Python anyone that watches my
website knows Monty Python so you can
probably see you know that I've taken
good jokes from them too but um I love
the sir reality of those sketches I love
the fact they don't feel like they have
to be contained to a certain amount of
time I like the fact that they feel if
they run into a hole they can just do
whatever they want with it I love the
character archetypes they may I love the
jerky character I love the Pampas
character I love actually the one I've
grown to love the most
oddly enough is Erik idols really cheeky
optimistic character they plays a lot I
think he calls a mr. cheeky or whatever
by me it's just sort of this it's that
Eric Idle smile it's just how everything
is gonna be okay it's it's really
growing on me and I absolutely love
whatever Eric Idle is on screen I just
start laughing now because I love it but
you can throw any terrible thing at him
and he'll be fine to be totally okay
he's always looking on the uppers at the
bright side of life so love that the
animations by Gilliam are just great and
it's funny because I think the
interesting thing with Python is that
you sort of go from when you're a little
kid you're gonna laugh at it cuz it's
silly and you know when you're a
teenager you sort of get the the smarter
stuff
it's Killah older you sort of start to
say well that's an Revis you know this
isn't really as intelligent of a bubble
blah and then we reach another age yeah
I think maybe around this age again you
have this whole new respect for it for
just how unexpected and odd it is and I
think the animations are good are good
proof of that because at first it's like
well anyone can cut this out and just
move them around well why is this
anything great and when you really watch
it it's like wow the sir reality that
these cartoons are creating are just
phenomenal I mean they're they're so
bizarre they just play with the
conventions of just what you're seeing
you know and what can be done with just
layers and you know and lines and stuff
like that and it's it's always sort of
going against that convention
and it's a lot of fun but on top of that
the writings great the acting is great
the acting especially is really great in
a lot of these the fact that they'll go
from once gets to another with these
weird sort of segues I think is always
great it that's got to be hard to put
together you know it's got to be hard to
always link these up somehow and they
did just a great job of that and they
sir create their own little world you
know with them linking things up and
then running jokes and stuff like that I
love that's if you want learn how
perfective running joke watch Monty
Python they were so good at having jokes
come back later in the episode sometimes
even other episodes so like you know
some sketches don't always work you know
something dude just fall flat I mean
that that's the Neve that's any comedian
and any break routines you know I have
Andy they always have some that don't
work but the stuff that does work is is
so clever and so I think a lot of is
just where did it come from where did
this material evolve from and how did it
get to this point the sir reality of it
is just so wonderful so really really
enjoying it just great stuff the movies
of course are great meaning of life's
okay I'll get some great ideas God knows
that but yeah just just really love me a
Monty Python I love pelvic sketch work I
love the movies I love writing acting
all good stuff The Simpsons
I think the funny thing about the
Simpsons is that like everyone I'm not a
huge fan of the senses now I don't
really even watch it much anymore
sometimes you'll get a laugh but it's
mostly whatever just sort of throw away
it mostly just makes you remember the
old citizens but when the Simpsons were
their prime it I think it's one of those
things where it was so massive and so
big and so influential you sort of
forget about it and it's sort of the
same thing we're at thinking back I
realized that what I like about this
show is the fact again
like the goofy cartoons everyone is
served in the same world they're all
sort of power-hungry and what you know
what they feel is coming to them and
they also have a certain level stupidity
and I think when you make an entire
world sort of like that just varying
levels of stupidity that's fun because
that's always that feels sort of like a
social commentary like no this really is
embedded into us these are just
different levels of idiocy of family and
that they all are greedy they all are
large they all are you know can be
obnoxious people you know what you think
won't be obnoxious somehow turn into
obnoxious people oh and I there's great
comedy in that and I say it's more this
world they free of this world of
characters the simpsons themselves are
actually just okay Homer starts to get
low grading at times you know if Bart's
pretty good even then sometimes stories
can wear a little thin margin lease are
usually pretty boring
thankee actually it's always funny I
just realized there's never a time when
Maggie isn't funny ever realize that so
so she's probably the funniest one but
but I mean they all have the really
funny moments it's the world that they
inhabit and that they live around and
against are like my Python playing with
expectation where you think when Homer
does something stupid oh it's gonna be
funny because he's gonna look dumb but
in this world it's actually accepted and
I like that I like this world that Soros
celebrates this idiocy but they think
they're being really smart they think
they're being really intelligent and
again it's does sir create more of a
social commentary against our parks are
do that as well so I like things more
like that there's only so many times
people can act stupid and the rest of
the world goes oh you know in various
ways that gets old it's funnier if you
create this world or this environment
where this is accepted and it's okay and
then we become the street people we are
the ones laughing at it so yeah really
love the energy it really it really did
change a lot and I think all of us
really
we take so much of our humor from The
Simpsons when you really think about it
it's so huge that we forget how much we
got from it I think and I think growing
up with it you know and even having it
now as I show right now it's probably
not the worst is just compared to what
it was it's not as hot but we really did
get so much of our tea of this
generation got so much of our humor from
The Simpsons I mean there's just no
question about it the way we talk the
way we point out the obvious things you
know in obvious ways you know that's the
joke is just help what we are now and
how is stupid our generations become and
we celebrate and stuff so much of that
came from the Simpsons and their
constant use of that so place it it's
the citizens you don't even have to talk
that much about it
number two Mystery Science Theater 3000
now the fun thing about this remember I
was saying before about something is so
big that you sort of forget about it
it's just so commonplace Mystery Science
I want to put this list together I
forgot about Mystery Science Theater and
I often do but it is obviously such a
big influence the way they comment on
things and that's all they're doing
they're just commenting on what they're
seeing which you could argue is all
satire but just the wave the way they
say things the words they choose the
fact that they have to fit it in this
amount of time and the fact that I think
what's what's really funny about Mystery
Science thing I think why it's funny
that saying this to a screen instead of
reenacting something really works is
that when they say it like like they're
one of the characters I will say a
person talks like this and they make mmm
review and just be like you know oh I'm
Superman is that you whatever some funny
it's funny because it sounds like
they're really putting themselves in the
movie and that the characters in the
film just don't even notice they don't
notice how stupid something sounds or
something is and I think when you're
constantly inserting yourself like that
that's why it's funny because
it seems like the stupidity of what
you're seeing is not even being affected
by the logic that you're shouting at it
and I think that's what they discovered
and they perfected so well and I think
fitting it in the pauses whenever a
character is talking and there's a
little pause in there and trying to fit
it in there real fast is really good
because that's sort of like you know
when somebody's saying something and you
you know I mumble something I'm here
11:00 or something like that if that's
what's funny is the fact that you say
something it just it doesn't even affect
what's going on it's like oh here's some
logic for you it doesn't matter okay
because the whatever they're looking at
where the satirizing is so embedded in
their stupid stupid world that it
doesn't even have an effect and I think
that's what makes Mystery Science
Theater so funny and the concept of
making fun of these movies so funny
and again the writing just great you
know the Mike Nelson get Murphy you know
all those guys I mean are just so good
and what they do and the deadpan the
various ways of delivery there you know
the deadpan or the excited or imitating
the voice you know just works so well
and like I said obviously watching the
stache' Creek you can tell anything a
lot from them to point the audio over
them they good started something the
same way the Simpsons started something
with that sort of new line of humor I
think they really started something too
and they like I said I think we often
forget about it but it's another thing
that it's so embedded in our minds now
Simpsons is probably a little bigger in
what influence a hand everybody cuz that
if that was more popular but with
Mystery Science Theater the people that
get into it it it sticks with them and
it has an effect on their sense of humor
and I guarantee anyone that watches it
and enjoys it like it will affect the
way they say things and the way they
look at things and the way they talk
about things it's just they've really
found something good with that formula
they did such a good job using it and
then poking fun at writing for it I'm
sure you all of Mystery Science Theater
what else guys
and the number one comedic influence is
Daffy Duck I'm sure a lot of you already
knew this if I shouldn't just say Daffy
Duck I should say willing Tunes in
general with a big emphasis on Daffy
Duck these cartoons these are some of
the earliest things I've ever seen and I
love them the the energy from um the
intelligence from them these characters
are so funny and the one I love the most
is Daffy Duck because he's the loser
he's the one that always wants to win if
he tries so hard to win and things just
never go his way and you never know is
it because the world is against him that
he's this way or is it because he's
dissuaded the world's against him you
can play off either scenario and just
the animation the timing the writing
that comes from these cartoons are so
great as somebody said that if Disney
was classical music then Warner Brothers
was contemporary jazz and I think it's a
very good way of putting it it
waterbirds you know in Disney's
phenomenal don't get me wrong
um Warner Brothers sort of you know
what's like Disney but they're sort of
doing their own thing as well make sure
I had the similar Disney style animation
but they just did whatever they wanted
they did what they thought was funny not
what they thought other people was gonna
be funny and so much good humor comes
from that just do what you think is
funny don't worry too much about what
whatever people are gonna say about and
you can just tell it's you can sense the
fun people were having when they were
making this I think he also got that
from Animaniacs you got how much fun
people had just writing this and coming
up with the ideas and coming up with
these characters and now with that said
with Daffy Duck because they're sort of
this I just called John Kay a guy who
create Ren Stimpy has this huge thing
maybe rightfully so about Daffy Duck
there's these two versions one is you
know really crazy and jumping up and
down oh you know just pure anarchy and
silliness and the other one the more
contemporary one that we know is the
jealous
kirk and he didn't like the jealous jerk
and I can understand that um I like both
I think that's part of the what's fun
about is that there are so are these two
versions and really as time goes on it
dis are working the way cuz Daffy was
sort of gonna be the big star for this
report porky was gonna be the star them
daddy came along he became really big
and then bugs came along and he took
over the spotlight and Daffy serve
wasn't as popular so it sort of made
sense to have it go in that direction
but I love both I loved the silliness I
love the anarchy but I also love just
the desperation to want to be the star
to want to be appreciated by everybody
and just never ever works and the harder
you try to make it you know come your
way the bigger it's going to blow up in
your face I I think the reason we like
my happens to him is because he's trying
to take something away from someone else
and he knows he's doing it he has no
problem he'd almost prefer it so I think
that's why we have no problem when bad
things happen to him I think my favorite
Daffy moment it's another one of those
sort of a trilogy of Elmer Fudd Daffy
Duck Bugs Bunny is there in the snow and
Daffy keeps trying to convince Elmer as
you know you know it's rabbit season
shoot the rabbit and the whole episode
was just trying to get him to understand
this what to get if he was a hunting
with shot of both right away but you
know he's not very bright he loses to
all of this and everything you know bugs
always has a trick to make it so that
Daffy gets shot every time and he keeps
trying to say no you shoot him you shoot
and he always gets shot and finally at
the end he cracks he just goes crazy and
he turns to me again I love the feathers
and he just wails on if he just goes
nuts and it's just a wonderful breakdown
and I think I think you never see Bugs
Bunny cracker and maybe he didn't feel
but it was out of character and Bugs
Bunny ever cracked over something and
that's why I like to have a dog Maura
it's just this great he shows the
weakness he shows the vulnerability and
the patheticness and we all like to
laugh at him because I think we feel
that patheticness as well at times Bugs
Bunny is who we want to be I think Daffy
Duck is who we are and that's why I like
Daffy a lot more how I play bad guys
more I like playing the jerks more I
love all of that because they get the
bigger laughs there's much more weakness
I think we see much more of ourselves in
you know those sad pathetic people and I
love the good guys I love there should
be a Bugs Bunny and we should look up to
them and we should try to be like that
that's wonderful for me I enjoy the
vulnerable people a little bit more if
they really have fun with why they're
vulnerable
so yeah guys those are my top 15 comedic
influences I know there's others out
there but these are the top 15 that have
like the biggest impact I think growing
up and for what I do these really really
like I'm constantly referencing these
guys whenever I'm thinking of something
funny um I hope you enjoyed this that's
about it I'm out here